it seems that everything that I really
care about what the passion takes a long
time because it takes me a long time to
really um I guess kind of test myself
about how really compelled interested I
am in any one subject and it takes me a
long time to really figure that out and
in this case this took a lot of reading
there's what 7,500 books working on
Lincoln and everybody feels they own
Lincoln who wrote the book my interest
was first sparked when I met Doris
Kearns Goodwin for the first time she
said she was writing a book about
Abraham Lincoln's presidency and the
first thing out of my mouth was are the
film rights available and she said yes
they are and that's how it all began for
me the research that I've done has
changed my life its reorganized the
molecules of my being it's not just that
Lincoln himself was one of the greatest
writers and one of the most luminous
individuals in all of human history the
people who write about him write about
him with an incredible depth and grace
and courage and it's been a just it's
been very very difficult but it's been
an enormous joy to work on I began from
knowing absolutely nothing about him or
his life having only the the
mythologized image that most of us are
introduced to what I invariably don't do
and haven't done it is to dismember a
life into its component parts and work
upon one aspect of the life and then
another to separate it somehow in the
hope that having explored and
investigated those different areas
somehow some magical spell is going to
turn them into a cohesive whole so
you're always there playing with the
danger of self consciousness and self
consciousness is that as everyone knows
here I'm sure is is really the great
enemy that you struggle with so you need
to put that aside all the time just
close that down I need to
that there is some mystery involved
there may not be but but I choose to
believe that there is I had heard The
Doors current Goodwin's was writing a
book but originally I heard it was about
Abe and Mary and I went blank
and but I had no real agenda I had no
preconceived ideas I I did a lot of
research and I had Tony Kushner's
magnificent text and the unbelievably
superb shepherd ship of Steven Spielberg
you just jump I will say there's no
better producer than the one sitting
next to me and oftentimes what Steven
and I talk about is what the approach is
to the movie from the beginning and we
knew that this was going to be a
difficult movie to get made and we knew
that there wasn't a guarantee that there
would be an audience so we knew right
from the beginning that we would make
this for a price if we could and every
single aspect of the moviemaking process
we approached with that in mind and we
got very very fortunate in that we went
into Richmond Virginia where the film
Commission was able to give us all the
government buildings while they were out
of session so everything you're seeing
that looks so much like the White House
and whatnot they're all the actual
buildings in Richmond Virginia one of
the things that has animated our 40
years together is a great variety from
one film to another from Indiana Jones
to Munich to whatever and it's always
fresh and it always seems new but this
particular piece is is there's something
transportational happening I think for
me in this film one of the best
definitions I've ever read about of
history is that history is what the
present prefers to think of the past and
and what's better about this piece is
that it's more objectified than that we
just entered into this world where the
crew was a part of it every
and I never saw the crew actually they
just sort of backed away and and we
stepped in and did our work and we were
just in this bubble and as far as I was
concerned there were three people in the
scene my darling mr. Lincoln
Molly Mary in this person that came and
dropped down and whispered things in my
ears and was like crawling on the floor
he was always in the scene it was Steven
was everywhere never never leaving the
set I think it's exciting about
history's talking about politics is the
humanity of it I mean there's this great
Emerson this thing that Emerson wrote
that politics is the is the movement of
the soul Illustrated in power there were
so many clues throughout all the
scholarly writings about this entire
period of time Thaddeus Stevens said
13th amendment you know the greatest
amendment of the 19th century you know
you know passed by corruption aided and
abetted by the purest man in America you
know quote unquote Thaddeus Stevens
so Tony likes Anthony watches CSI but it
was like a CSI investigator